un papá visiblemente cansado ha admitido
que tal vez tendrá que bajar el ritmo en
declaraciones a los periodistas de
vuelta de un viaje de alto nivel a
canadá el pontífice de 85 años ha dicho
que no descartará su retiro si su salud
le impide continuar con su apretada
agenda de viajes internacionales no solo
no creo que no creo que pueda seguir
haciendo viajes con el mismo ritmo que
antes y manu creo que a la de con
cuesta creo que a mí gratis y con esta
limitación tengo que ahorrar un poco
para poder servir a la iglesia o decidir
dar un paso al costado es tu punto de
honestidad no es una catástrofe un papá
puede ser cambiado no hay ningún
problema con eso esto contador está
durante gran parte de la visita del
pontífice dependió de una silla de
ruedas debido a un dolor en la rodilla
el papá francisco sufre del nervio
ciático y una rotura de ligamentos en la
rodilla y se ha visto ralentizado por
una importante operación intestinal
realizada el año pasado en la que se le
extirpó parte del colon este fue el
viaje internacional número 37 de
francisco desde que se convirtió en papá
en 2013 describiéndolo como una
peregrinación de penitencia el pontífice
aprovechó su visita para pedir perdón
por el daño causado a las comunidades
indígenas por las escuelas residenciales
gestionadas por la iglesia que se
convirtieron en foco de abusos toledo y
babín
cambiar la cultura cambiar la mente
quitar a los niños cambiar la cultura
cambiar las mentes cambiar las
tradiciones cambiar una raza por así
decirlo toda una cultura si es una
palabra técnica que nos y b2 y es un
genocidio no lo utilice porque no se me
ocurrió pero la de escribir es cierto sí
sí es un genocidio medias
el pontífice dice que tiene previsto
cumplir sus compromisos de visitar
países como sudán del sur y la república
democrática del congo pero que retrasará
la planificación de nuevas visitas hasta
que tenga la oportunidad de evaluar su
salud